así bien lo que estamos viendo ahora es
el inicio de este proceso tradicional
conocido como rouco en donde se comienza
a llamar estado por estado para saber en
este conteo nacional de delegados cuál
es el apoyo para el candidato en
específico y aunque el partido demócrata
ha centrado esta convención en job airén
recordemos que bernie sanders prefirió
también estar en este conteo permanecer
en los tarjetones de las primarias
aunque anunciara su retiro de manera
anticipada para poder negociar esa
plataforma que tendrá el partido
demócrata durante estos comicios y
después de que sea elegido el candidato
oficial entonces esto le daría mayor el
poder de negociación y claro lo que
estamos viendo es
una división de quienes apoyan a vader y
a sanders porque precisamente ese es uno
de los retos uno de los varios retos que
tiene el partido demócrata ya que como
hemos visto también se ha centrado
muchísimo esta convención en las figuras
más importantes en el a la más
tradicional demócrata que son los
clinton también se encuentran los
kennedy y son representan digamos esa a
la más poderosa de los demócratas porque
en unas elecciones no sólo se necesita
tener una buena plataforma sino
capacidad de recaudar fondos de
mantenerse en una campaña presidencial
por eso es que hemos visto también como
la convención ha tratado de darle más
participación a figuras locales y
estatales del partido demócrata y
también como pues tendrá que enfrentar
otros retos como el que las personas o
muchos electores no salgan a votar o no
voten
a través de correo debido a la pandemia
por temor a la seguridad pero también a
la estrategia del presidente de donald
trump de desprestigio del sistema
electoral en los eeuu también tendrán
que hacer frente a cómo lo mencionábamos
ese apoyo que tienen los más
progresistas que está que estábamos
viendo en el discurso de ocasión cortes
pidiendo específicas medidas en esta
agenda como incrementar el salario
mínimo a los trabajadores que haya
educación para todos en los eeuu de
manera gratuita y acceso al sistema de
salud esas políticas y esas peticiones
que está haciendo sanders y que están
haciendo también los más progresistas
dentro del partido se van a estar
negociando dentro de esta convención y
de hecho
sanders y bailén se reunieron antes de
que sanders le diera oficialmente un
hace unos meses atrás el apoyo a
joe biden así que esto lo que está
ocurriendo ahora y de manera simbólica
vimos también cómo le dio el apoyo a
bailén una vigilante que se encontró con
él en el ascensor y que decidió
convertirse como ya lo decía en amiga de
bailén porque le gustaba su plataforma y
ella salió dándole también el apoyo un
apoyo simbólico al candidato ba